Did you know that a crowd
of New Yorkers once filled a hall,
with thousands more awaiting word outside,
and that the police had to come
and forbid the selling
of additional tickets,
and that the "New York Times"
used the phrase --
a phrase not yet a cliché --
that people were "packed like sardines"?
And did you know that this frenzy
was all because people
were desperate to watch
a woman walk in circles on sawdust?
(Laughter)
The sport was pedestrianism --
when watching people walk
was America's pastime.
(Laughter)
I won’t get too deep into the story
of our pedestrian, Ada Anderson,
and the breathless “New York Times”
articles about her walk:
2,700 quarter miles
in 2,700 consecutive quarter hours.
I bring up this long-ago event
for a singular purpose:
to question what you think you know
about why we watch sports.
If people lost their minds
watching someone walk in circles,
(Laughter)
what can this teach us
about the heart of sports?
Understanding what compels us
to watch sports,
it's not just a thought experiment,
although it is that,
but it's more.
It could have tangible effects.
If we're willing to inspect
what actually spikes our heart rate
and pushes us to the edge of our seats,
instead of just assuming we know,
we can all, collectively, make
the sports world a more equitable place.
I didn't say "equal," I said "equitable."
Fair, evenhanded, just.
Often, if you ask someone
why they watch sports,
they will tell you because they want
to watch the best of the best.
Anything else ...
isn't worth their time.
This reasoning ...
it presents itself as biological.
The men’s sprint champion --
always a half-second faster
than the women's sprint champion.
The men of the NBA --
most of them can jump higher
than the women of the WNBA,
and on, and on ...
If we passively accept this premise
that the only sports worth watching
are those played at the apex of humanity,
then we have baked into our sports world
a reason for why women's sports don't ...
and can't ...
and won't matter.
For example:
"Call me when women can dunk"
is a thing that people have long said.
(Laughter)
Yeah, alright, so we're dunking now.
"Actually, you know what?
Call me when women can do 360 dunks."
2050 here, on the line.
“Yeah, alright.
We’re doing 360 dunks now too.
Ah, yeah, alright. We’ll call you, then.”
You get it.
So let me lay out my theory for you.
My theory about what actually
compels us to watch sports.
I spent seven years as a columnist
and feature writer at ESPN,
and I did shows like "Around the Horn,"
"Outside the Lines," "First Take."
And we would always look
at the sports calendar
and try to pinpoint moments
when women's sports would be big --
like, really big.
And it was always the same two events,
the Olympics, then the World Cup.
Then, the Olympics.
Toss some tennis in there,
but mostly the Olympics and the World Cup.
And so we got to thinking:
What is it about these two events?
What are the common factors that allow
women's sports to transcend
for these fleeting moments?
Because even at the Olympics,
the men's swim times
are just a fraction of a second
faster than the women's.
These two events have
two crucial elements in common:
stakes and storylines.
This is what burns
at the center of sports.
In the Olympics, we have all agreed
a gold medal matters.
Same with the World Cup.
And now, paired with
these agreed-upon stakes,
we also have -- at the Olympics
and the World Cup --
very obvious storylines.
One person has a USA jersey on,
someone else has
a different country's jersey on.
Alright.
We’ve got agreed-upon stakes,
we’ve got very obvious storylines --
of course, now, we're going
to have a commitment
to even deeper storytelling,
which is how we end up teary-eyed
after a three-and-a-half-minute
NBC vignette about a Romanian gymnast.
(Laughter)
You have everything you need, now,
for the next two hours of competition.
An Olympic gold medal is on the line.
And you’ve got your storyline.
A Romanian gymnast
desperately overcoming the odds.
Boom.
Storylines drive up the stakes.
Higher stakes -- more storylines,
and on and up we go.
Every so often,
a female athlete or a team,
they will hit the tipping point.
We understand their storylines,
we’ve got the stakes.
Here, I'm thinking Serena Williams,
Simone Biles, Ronda Rousey,
Megan Rapinoe.
Right?
These are the outliers.
And having representation matters.
But what tends to happen
is that these handful of female athletes
carry the media burden
for all of women's sports.
Not only that --
the media gets to say
"Yeah, we checked that box, we're good.
We did that thing,
we put so-and-so on the cover,
like, seven years ago.
We're good."
What doesn’t happen
is the pursuit of additional storylines,
expanding the breadth of our storytelling,
which is what is continually
happening on the men's side.
When I worked at ESPN
and I would do a TV show,
I was in the production room,
and I was always pitching
women's sports stories.
It almost never worked.
Every once in a while, it would work.
And the thing about doing sports on TV ...
is that you are not actually an expert
at everything you're talking about.
(Laughter)
But you read, you do your homework,
you figure out a position.
But this thing would happen
when we would do a women's sports segment:
Many of the other men on the segment ...
didn’t really do their homework.
So they were kind of "blah."
Then, the segment would be kind of "blah."
There's actually a term for this,
it's called "gender bland."
And then, the segment would end,
and the producer would be like,
"See? This is why we never
do women's sports,
because they're boring."
When a men's segment fell flat,
the problem was us.
We would redo it.
"Alright, come on, do your homework.
Pick it up. We're doing that again."
When a segment
on women's sports fell flat,
the problem was women's sports.
This is a microcosm
for how this plays out across media.
Never finding the new angle,
never finding the new story.
So what you do
is you rely on the millions of stories
that already exist.
And you know what already exists?
Every men's sports story imaginable.
(Laughter)
The reality is that just existing
in our culture,
you will know a dozen men’s storylines.
I mean, these things are literally
push-notified to your phone.
Or you're sitting behind someone
on an airplane,
and you can’t help but see
what they’re watching on ESPN.
Or you’re at a bar, or a doctor’s office,
and the talking heads are giving you
the latest NBA drama.
In America, osmosis will have you knowing
men’s sports storylines.
(Laughter)
And by the way,
when men have a daughter
and they finally get women's sports,
what they're really saying is,
they finally have a front-row seat
to the stakes and the storylines.
Let's go back in time again.
Philadelphia, 1931.
The Philadelphia Quicksteppers,
an all-Black women's basketball team,
led by a legend, Inez Patterson.
Patterson, she knows a thing or two
about storylines.
She's ahead of her time.
So she goes to the local
all-Black newspaper,
"The Philadelphia Tribune,"
and she proposes a deal.
Sponsorship.
Storylines in exchange for naming rights.
This may very well be the first
naming-rights deal in history.
The Philadelphia Quicksteppers
become the Philadelphia Tribunes.
And I bring this up
because the very next year, 1932,
there's an intracity rival --
the Germantown Hornets
with Ora Washington, very famous player.
And they decide, the two of them --
Germantown, the Tribunes --
to play a five-game series to determine
the best team in Philadelphia.
Remember, storylines
was part of the deal.
Five-game series goes to a fifth game.
And this is how the "Tribune" writes
about the atmosphere in game five, 1932:
"The cash customers fanned to fever heat
by the ardor and closeness of combat
gave outlet to all kinds
of riotous impulses."
Alright?
This may not sound familiar yet,
but our girl, Ada Anderson?
1879, the "New York Times"
writes about her walk.
Her walk.
"Many women were seen to faint
in the dense crowd,
but as they could not be carried out,
it is not known what became of them."
(Laughter)
Hot damn, y'all, people
loved ladies' sports, right?
(Laughter)
I mean ...
(Applause)
Who knew?
Well, wherever you find
compelling storylines
and agreed-upon stakes,
you will find people
on the edge of their seat.
No matter the vertical leap
of the participant.
So ...
Who tells the storylines
of women’s sports today?
Many of you will know the statistic
I'm about to put up.
University of Southern California,
Purdue University,
released in 2021,
studying the year 2019
in sports media coverage.
Of all of the minutes
of ESPN's SportsCenter in 2019,
5.1 percent of them
given to women's sports.
You know what's really sad
about this number?
It's that it's not even
as high as it looks,
because 2019 was a Women's World Cup year.
Audience: Woo-hoo.
KF: What happens when you take out
the Women’s World Cup minutes?
3.5 percent
of all of the minutes of SportsCenter ...
given to women's sports.
Now what if I told you that number
is even higher than it seems?
Because what mostly makes up that number
is, like, a game recap,
a quick highlight.
We call these "one-and-dones."
There is nothing to think about.
There's no follow-up.
It is a “storyline” for a reason,
because a "line" keeps going.
(Laughter)
A game recap is not a storyline.
What drives interest in sports
are the heroes and the villains,
and the "Were they paid too much?"
and "Should that coach be fired?"
Something to really sink your teeth into
and to stake a position on.
Do you know that ESPN
has had the rights to the WNBA
all 26 years of the league's existence?
And in that time,
not one studio show was ever made
to introduce people to these storylines
of the WNBA.
People will tell you that number
reflects consumer demand.
But that number reflects one thing --
that number.
Who can want more of something
they have never been given?
And how can we believe
we want more of something
if the reasons for not wanting it
are biological?
That feels pathological.
Remember Ada Anderson?
Remember the Philadelphia Tribunes?
"The cash customers fanned to fever heat."
And why did they fan the fever heat?
Because our collective love of sport
is deep, and it's human,
and it's driven by deep
and human motivations.
The physical expression of athleticism
is just one element of the equation.
But somehow, for reasons we know,
it has been elevated above all else
to justify our current model.
This is a model built ...
without vision,
meant to, reluctantly,
provide women a small place.
But never ...
not really, a chance.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)